Trascrizione: Alice Andreola
Revisore: Maria D
È stato un vero privilegio per me oggi,
poter passeggiare
per le strade di Matera.
E pensavo che noi, da italiani,
quasi diamo per scontato
posti così magici,
dove veramente il nostro passato,
un passato glorioso e antico,
è lì e lo vediamo e ci viviamo
ancora in mezzo.
E non è solo una cosa italiana,
perché è proprio il Mediterraneo
che spesso è chiamato
la "culla della civilizzazione"
e io, lavorando ad Al Jazeera,
spesso vado anche nei paesi
della sponda sud del Mediterraneo
e ovviamente cosa c'é:
c'é l'Antico Egitto,
ci sono i territori palestinesi,
Israele, la Terra Santa
la Siria dove Aleppo credo sia
la città dove c'é stata
abitazione continua
più antica in tutto il mondo.
E anche magari restando
dalla sponda europea,
e poi vediamo anche la Grecia
con la sua storia.
Però mi ha fatto anche pensare
che un passato glorioso
non è ovviamente una garanzia
di un buon presente
e forse anche di un buon futuro.
Perché guardiamo questi paesi:
l'Egitto che sta cercando
di avere una democrazia che funzioni
e che sia giusta, e che fino ad ora
più o meno sta fallendo.
La Siria non ne parliamo neanche,
è straziata da una guerra civile
che ormai va avanti da anni
e non si vede fine.
La Grecia colpita da una crisi profonda
che veramente sta sfibrando la società.
E anche noi sappiamo bene,
che stiamo avendo dei seri problemi.
Noi la chiamiamo "crisi economica",
forse, si potrebbe anche chiamare
una "metamorfosi."
Perché credo che la crisi
abbia evidenziato
che c'erano dei problemi in un sistema
che non funzionava.
E chi sta decidendo per noi?
Beh, i giovani.
Si dice sempre che l'Italia
non è un paese per i giovani,
e dev'essere strano, per me,
essere un giovane per le strade di Matera,
camminare e vedersi circondati da questo
passato così glorioso e così antico,
però sentire anche allo stesso tempo
una depressione per il futuro
sentirsi sempre quasi sfortunati
di essere nati
in un periodo che tutti dicono
sia di crisi.
Perciò cosa stanno facendo questi ragazzi?
Beh, tanti di loro se ne stanno andando.
Io vivo a Londra da vent'anni, e
gli ultimi anni sono stati impressionanti.
Io sento l'italiano ovunque.
Avvocati, banchieri,
il ragazzo che fa il caffé.
C'è anche ad Al Jazeera,
nel nostro dipartimento di finanze,
una ragazza italiana.
Perciò veramente
stanno arrivando in tantissimi.
E io sono una grande fan di fare
delle esperienze di lavoro all'estero,
ma questo è diverso,
questo non è la "fuga dei cervelli"
questo è la fuga di tutti,
perché non vedono più un futuro qui.
E cosa stanno andando
a cercare a Londra?
Stanno cercando quella parola magica,
che noi sentiamo tantissimo
nel nostro discorso nazionale
qui in Italia.
E quella parola è "meritocrazia".
Noi vediamo la meritocrazia
come la soluzione a tanti dei nostri mali.
Forse a tutti i nostri mali,
iniziando ovviamente dal nepotismo,
che noi sappiamo benissimo deve cambiare,
che noi sappiamo non sta dando
le vere possibilità al nostro paese.
Ma, a mio avviso, e lo dico
dopo vent'anni a Londra,
e una vita all'estero, sfortunatamente,
mi è sempre mancata l'Italia
non ho preso io la decisione di andarmene,
però con la famiglia siamo andati via
quando avevo solo otto anni.
E io credo che
nel discorso nazionale italiano
si sia frainteso cosa sia,
in effetti, la meritocrazia.
Perché è vista come antidoto al nepotismo,
è vista come antidoto a tutto
è vista come la nostra soluzione,
è vista come una cosa positiva, e lo è,
ma non è solo una cosa positiva.
Perché la meritocrazia
ha anche un lato negativo,
o, per lo meno, un lato spietato.
Perché la meritocrazia,
come la intendo io, non premia i bravi,
la meritocrazia non premia
chi ha studiato.
Alla meritocrazia non importa niente
se hai preso 110 e lode.
La meritocrazia non premia
chi lavora duro,
e in un certo senso la meritocrazia
non premia chi se lo merita.
La meritocrazia premia i migliori
e agli altri vanno gli avanzi.
A Londra arrivano cinquemila persone nuove
che si trasferiscono ogni settimana.
Ed è un'immigrazione di livello istruito
e tutti si stanno mettendo in gara.
A Londra ci sono tante opportunità
ma quando c'è un lavoro e mille domande
il lavoro andrà ad una persona,
il o la migliore.
E perciò, per me, è molto fuorviante
parlare di meritocrazia
se non si parla anche
delle sue due sorelle gemelle,
forse non identiche, ma
sicuramente sorelle gemelle:
competizione e ambizione.
Io a volte parlo con dei ragazzi italiani
che vengono a Londra e mi chiedono:
"Barbara, non capisco cosa stai dicendo,
cosa vuol dire competizione?
Io vedo questo lavoro,
mando il mio curriculum,
cos'altro dovrei fare?"
E ci ho pensato molto
alle risposte che cerco di dare,
e mi ha fatto venire in mente
un litigio che io avevo avuto
tantissimi anni fa,
quando avevo venti, ventun'anni
con un amico, che si chiama Matteo,
italiano, molto più italiano di me,
nel senso che lui ora viaggia,
ma è nato e cresciuto in Italia.
Parlavamo del compito in classe.
Io avevo confessato che,
non solo ero una tale secchiona
che non avevo mai copiato,
però anche che io non avevo
e non avrei mai lasciato copiare
il mio compito ad un compagno.
Perciò non avrei aiutato
un compagno di classe
facendogli copiare il mio compito.
Apriti cielo!
Matteo me ne ha dette di cotte e di crude,
"Ma che antipatica che sei!",
"Ma che male ti fa?",
"Perché non dovresti aiutare un amico?"
E poi mi diceva:
"Non sai mai quando sarai tu che
avrai bisogno dell'aiuto!"
E ci ho pensato molto perché
quando si litiga con un amico,
e siamo ancora amici ora,
perciò la nostra amicizia
è soppravvissuta a quel litigio,
però quando litighi con un amico
per una cosa così basilare
allora pensi: "Beh, sono io, allora,
che ho sbagliato, o lui,
com'è che siamo così diversi?"
E allora io ho pensato,
dopo anni ci sono arrivata,
che era basato sul fatto che io,
avendo fatto le scuole anglosassoni,
durante la mia istruzione accademica,
i voti che venivano dati a noi
erano dati in maniera molto diversa,
di quanto venissero dati a Matteo,
che ha fatto la scuola italiana.
Per Matteo, metti in un compito in classe
il voto è su cento,
perciò dal 60% è sufficienza,
70%, 80% buono, molto buono,
se hai dal 90% in più hai il voto ottimo.
Ed era basato su quello che facevi tu.
Non era basato sul tuo voto
relativo al voto degli altri.
Io invece, nella scuola
inglese internazionale che ho fatto,
il mio voto era un po' così.
Questo si chiama:
"Modello di Valutazione Accademica
Anglosassone con Curva Gaussiana".
Una maniera molto complicata per spiegare
che il mio voto, invece, era relativo
al voto dei miei compagni di classe.
Perciò qui, diciamo su una classe
di trenta ragazzi,
come vedete dalla parte destra,
solo il 10% avrebbe avuto il voto ottimo.
Perciò su trenta ragazzi, solo tre
avrebbero avuto il voto ottimo.
E non importava perché tutti i voti
venivano messi su questa curva,
dove la maggioranza era nel mezzo,
c'era l'insufficianza e l'ottimo,
però solo una certa percentuale
sarebbe stata eccellente.
Cosa voleva dire allora?
Che tu potevi avere 99% come risultato
di un compito in classe,
ma se c'erano tre persone con 100%,
tu non avevi il voto ottimo.
Questo spiega perché copiare
è socialmente accettabile
nel sistema italiano.
Io sto usando l'esempio
del compito in classe,
poi, insomma, sappiamo che
si può adattare in altre situazioni.
Socialmente accettabile
in Italia, e non qui,
perché se fai copiare l'amico in Italia,
tu sei il simpaticone,
tu sei l'amico che ha aiutato l'altro,
e voi due insieme contro il sistema
avete vinto, e non avete
danneggiato nessun altro.
Se io qui, metti, ho uno dei voti ottimi,
aiuto un amico o amica
che avrebbe avuto la sufficianza e che
con il mio aiuto salta al "molto buono",
non è più un crimine senza vittime,
perché la gente dietro di lui
vedrà il suo voto abbassato
perché io ho lasciato copiare.
E allora far copiare non è più
socialmente accettabile.
È l'opposto, io non sono più
la simpaticona della classe,
io sono la cretina che sta danneggiando
i voti di tutti gli altri
per aiutare qualcuno che alla fin fine
non ha studiato.
Ora, questo può sembrare un esempio
un po' sempliciotto,
però questo mostra come la competizione
nel sistema anglosassone,
dove io ho fatto le scuole,
viene insegnata letteralmente a nove anni,
quando mi davano questi voti.
Perciò viene inculcata.
E io noto molto che i ragazzi italiani
non sono abituati a questo,
perché questo continua
non solo a scuola
tutte le università in America
e nel Regno Unito sono a numero chiuso,
perciò bisogna sempre far domanda,
è sempre una competizione.
Quando fai domanda devi dare i voti,
le scuole mostrano sempre nella pagella
se tu sei nel top 10%,
se tu eri fra i migliori.
Gli italiani non sono abituati a questo
e mi dispiace molto dire
che quando io vedo arrivare
i loro curriculum,
perché certi me li mandano ad Al Jazeera,
interessati al giornalismo,
o semplicemente se hanno il mio contatto,
per chiedere un consiglio
che io sono più che contenta di dare,
anzi è un onore,
però si vede che non ci sono abituati,
perché la verità è che i curriculum
dei ragazzi italiani
mostrano che loro non sono per niente
abituati a competere.
Non c'è frase che mi fa arrabbiare di più
di quando accendo un talk show in Italia,
e si sente la frase
"sì, a Londra c'è meritocrazia,
basta solo il curriculum".
Bene, allora io ora vi mostro
il curriculum che mi è arrivato
un paio di mesi fa
da una ragazza italiana,
ma in un certo senso
ancora meno italiana di me.
Lei si chiama Costanza Maio,
è nata a Perugia da genitori italiani
che però si sono trasferiti
a Philadelphia, in America,
quando lei aveva solo sei anni.
Per metterla così il suo accento italiano
è ancora peggio del mio.
Ecco qui il suo curriculum.
Costanza ha ora ventun'anni, qui venti.
Allora qui vediamo tutta l'istruzione.
Lei ora è all'università di New York,
e ha fatto vari stage ad Abu Dhabi,
negli Emirati Arabi Uniti,
e poi anche a Parigi,
anno sabatico in Spagna,
e questo non è vacanza, figli di papà,
queste sono tutte borse di studio,
e cose gratis che lei ha vinto.
Ma questa è solo la prima pagina,
questa è l'istruzione,
premi e borse di studio.
Costanza mi mostra subito
dove e quando lei è stata eccellente.
Se vediamo la seconda entrata,
quando dice "Dean's List",
questo è ciò di cui parlavo prima,
il top 10% di una scuola.
E continua, guardate lì il premio
"Impatto Globale" con "BuildOn"
che è una organizzazione non governativa,
con cui lei ha lavorato spesso,
perciò non erano solo ovviamente
cose pagate.
Qui vediamo le esperienze professionali.
Se vedete in basso sulla destra,
vedete che inizia a diciotto anni,
la prima esperienza professionale,
e vedete anche la seconda è
"Casa Italiana" a New York,
che, se andiamo a New York,
ci dovremmo passare,
e da quanto mi ha detto,
lei praticamente era alla reception.
Perciò non lavori
che avevano un impatto con i suoi studi
o in cui lei vedeva il suo futuro,
ma esperienze di lavoro.
E continua!
Esperienze internazionali,
anche qui vedete, diciannove, diciott'anni
la prima è andata in Mali, in Africa
a quindici anni, per due settimane.
E qui esperienze extra accademiche,
tutte le cose che faceva oltre lo studiare
che le università in America guardano
perché vogliono vedere gente
che veramente è attiva, che può non
essere il massimo accademicamente,
però può avere altri interessi.
E qui le sue competenze alla fine
me le mette, insomma,
le lingue, ovviamente, ha studiato
e mi fa vedere.
Ma quello che veramente è impressionante
del curriculum di Costanza,
guardatelo così, guardate le colonne.
La colonna sinistra è dai quindici
ai diciassette anni,
poi l'altra colonna è dei diciotto anni,
diciannove anni, venti e ventuno.
Ha solo un'entrata
perché, quando l'ha fatto
aveva appena compiuto
ventun anni.
Guardate la colonna di sinistra.
Quindici - diciassette anni.
Questi sono lavoretti o quello che
noi definiremmo lavoretti.
Ma sono esperienza, ed è anche la colonna
in un certo senso, più farcita di cose.
Da quella colonna dipendono
tutte le altre colonne.
Ora io vi dico una cosa: quando io vedo
i curriculum dei ragazzi italiani
che mi mandano i curriculum a Londra,
quella colonna non esiste.
E non esiste neanche veramente
diciotto, diciannove anni.
O se esiste è minima.
Ora, io lo so
che è molto difficile in Italia
per una questione di mentalità
noi non ci siamo abituati,
io so che molte famiglie vedono anche
insomma, far lavorare i ragazzi
da giovani in maniera un pochino negativa.
So anche che è molto difficile
avere uno stage.
Parlavo con Beppe Severgnini,
del Corriere della Sera,
un mio caro amico e collega,
e lui mi ha detto una frase
che mi ha fatto ridere e che è più facile
far entrare un giaguaro
nella redazione del Corriere della Sera
che non un minorenne.
Perciò io so che
ci sono tante difficoltà,
però ogni volta che mi arriva
un curriculum di un ragazzo italiano
e io ho sempre l'istinto,
giustamente o forse no,
di volere aiutare un italiano,
legame di sangue,
però quando io lo vedo,
e vedo che è abbastanza sgualcito,
c'è una parte di me che vuole chiedere:
"Nell'estate dai quindici
ai diciassette anni,
con tutta quella esperienza estiva,
dico nell'estate dei quindici,
sedici, diciassette anni,
eri per tre mesi sotto l'ombrellone
con famiglia e amici?
Nell'estate dei diciotto anni, eri sotto
l'ombrellone con famiglia e amici?
Per tre mesi?
Nell'estate dei diciannove,
venti e ventun'anni,
eri per tre mesi sotto l'ombrellone
con famiglia e amici?"
Perché se eri sotto l'ombrellone
per tutti quegli anni per tre mesi,
non so se hai veramente diritto
di piangere a ventitré anni
perché non hai nessuna
esperienza lavorativa
e non riesci a trovare uno stage.
(Applausi)
Non lo dico mai ai ragazzi italiani,
perché io so il contesto,
ma la realtà è che loro
magari mandano il curriculum a me
e io sono italiana, capisco,
e magari aiuto.
Ma se sono a Londra, lo stanno
mandando a gente che non è italiana,
e loro non capiscono,
e quella è la mentalità che avranno.
Questa è la competizione
e io ho chiesto a Costanza che,
vedendo il curriculum,
sembra una super antipatica,
invece è gentile, brava e tanto carina.
E io le ho chiesto: "Ma Costanza,
cos'è che ti ha spronato
già quand'eri piccolina
a fare queste cose?"
"Beh, l'ambizione".
Uh, l'ambizione.
Altra parola che non si sente mai
nel discorso italiano.
Io mi ricordo una volta alla Rai,
parlavo con una collega, e le ho detto:
"Beh sai, poi io sono ambiziosa"
e lei ha fatto "Sssh!"
Io ho detto [sottovoce] "Perché?"
"Non puoi dirlo!"
"Perché non posso dirlo?"
Veramente, così bisbigliavamo.
Lei fa: "Perché sembra brutto."
Perché nel nostro discorso
essere ambiziosi sembra brutto,
sa un po' di arrivismo,
sa un po' di andare a sgomitare,
di "Olgettine".
Poi se sei una donna e dici che
sei ambiziosa, hai voglia!
Però l'ambizione è chiave,
perché, in tutto questo discorso,
un'altra parola che viene fuori
nel discorso italiano
sa un po' di privilegio.
Tutte queste esperienze
di lavoro all'estero.
Quello che io sto descrivendo è la
versione europea del sogno americano.
Il sogno americano chi era?
Erano i nostri antenati,
perché mia mamma è siciliana,
io sono metà siciliana.
I nostri antenati non di secoli fa, del
secolo scorso, anche forse solo dopoguerra
che non avevano niente, avevano capito
che qui non avrebbero avuto futuro,
e l'ambizione li ha spinti
ad andare in America senza niente.
E la competizione e la meritocrazia
han fatto sì che ora,
dopo due generazioni
o quel che sia,
si sentono nomi italo-americani
in tutte le posizioni più alte in America.
Quella è l'ambizione, non ha niente
a che fare con il privilegio, è l'opposto.
È la maniera per riuscire a sfondare
se non sei nato con la fortuna.
Ora ci sono due ragioni --
(Applausi)
Ci sono due ragioni per le quali
ci tenevo a parlare di queste cose.
Uno, perché veramente mi colpisce
quello che sta succedendo
con tutti i ragazzi italiani
che arrivano a Londra.
Un paio di settimane fa avevo un uomo
di trentun anni che si è messo a piangere
al telefono perché veramente è così duro
scontrarsi con questo muro
soprattutto quando già si è
lasciata l'Italia con un po' di amarezza.
Perciò ci tenevo un po' a spiegare.
Non è solo una questione di chi va,
perché il vero lavoro è da fare qui.
E l'Italia è da cambiare qui,
e da cambiare ora.
E forse, questo sistema
non è giusto per noi.
Perciò io credo che ci sia bisogno
di un discorso di meritocrazia,
di usarlo in maniera giusta
e di usarlo in maniera nostra.
Noi non vogliamo essere una brutta copia
di paesi come il Regno Unito e l'America,
ma vogliamo essere
una versione più giusta,
più competitiva, della nostra cultura.
Per un futuro consapevole,
Italian style.
Grazie.